al edouard philippe membre du bureau
politique de l'ump et député maire du
havre est notre invité bonsoir bonsoir
également un proche d'alain juppé vous
seriez même son chouchou on a pu lire
cela de vous dans la presse si c'est
vrai c'est vrai ou pas oui je suis
proche de lui ça fait longtemps et on
s'aime bien oui voilà beaucoup vous
pouvez mutuellement très bien tous les
cas vous êtes ici dans le cadre bien sûr
de la campagne des départementales alors
attention à usage du mot nos pages
chouchou mais éminence avec la sortie du
livre sur l'imminence noire de nicolas
sarkozy patrick buisson de vous on
préférera je n'ai pas parlé d'éminence
grise non non j'en du tout une éminence
je suis un député maire heureux du havre
qui est non pas la mi mai j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec alain juppé
quand il était le président de l'ump et
depuis je n'ai pas quitté
parce que j'aime beaucoup parce que je
me retrouve beaucoup dans son discours
dans ses choix politiques dans son
action aussi politique et parce que j'ai
envie de l'accompagner
et de lui permettre d'accéder aux plus
hautes fonctions parce que je crois que
c'est ce dont notre pays a besoin c'est
pas un choix que je fais contre les
autres c'est un choix que je fais pour
jules d'accord vous interrogera sur ce
thème bien sûr et vous partager aussi le
même cursus avec alain juppé 1 il est
beaucoup plus brillantes mois il a plu
beaucoup à vous devez montrer que vous
êtes tourné galop - au cours de cette
émission c'est vous êtes d'accord au
cours de laquelle guillaume daudin de la
fp notre partenaire comme chaque semaine
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons d'abord bien sûr
l'attentât en tunisie et contre le musée
du bardo la france a exprimé bien sûr sa
solidarité après la mort d'une vingtaine
de personnes parce que tout des
touristes étrangers mais comment
traduire concrètement notre solidarité
avec ce pays ami et cette démocratie
toujours fragile oui c'est une
démocratie récente et c'est un attentat
terrible dont le en vérité je ne sais
rien il s'est passé aujourd'hui s'est
produit aujourd'hui la seule chose que
je sais c'est ce que j'ai pu en lire sur
twitter où dans les dépêches donc je ne
sais pas véritablement ce qui s'est
passé mais je peux malheureusement faire
l'analogie avec les situations que nous
avons connue en france à l'occasion
d'attentât ou en angleterre à l'occasion
d'attentats dramatique c'est toujours
une perturbation est un drame pour un
pays en l'occurrence on vise l'activité
touristique de la tunisie dont
fondamentale évidemment donc sont donc
ces ressources c'est donc une attaque
évidemment contre la démocratie
tunisienne il faut l'accompagner il faut
travailler avec avec les autorités
tunisiennes pour essayer de prévenir et
puis ensuite pour essayer de punir
mais c'est une c'est un sujet compliqué
et franchement à part des des
généralités que je que je dis
sincèrement mais qui n'ont pas un
intérêt considérable je crois que
l'important pour l'instant c'est
d'essayer de d'aider nos amis tunisiens
dans ce moment difficile et cette
attaque est survenue alors que le
parlement qui est voisin du musée
d'ailleurs a été saisie d'un nouveau
texte contre le terrorisme alors parlons
de la france si vous voulez bien un
consensus s'exprime sur le projet de loi
sur le renseignement que manuel valls a
présenté ce jeudi au conseil des
ministres mais la cnil s'inquiète des
menaces sur la vie privée une
surveillance intensive grâce à des
outils informatiques assez perfectionné
on comprend bien sûr la nécessité de
lutter contre les terroristes de
prévenir les attentats mais ce qu'il
s'agirait d'un patriot act français non
avoué
mais pas écoutés je ne sais pas je suis
vous dire je préfère vous dire je ne
sais pas même si c'est pas la mode chez
les hommes politiques de dire qu'ils ne
savent pas je ne sais pas pour une
raison très simple c'est que je n'ai pas
vu ce texte il sera présenté je crois je
dire au changement je dis conseil des
ministres pour l'instant le conseil
d'état l'a vu mais je ne sais pas ce qui
s'y est dit déjà l'ump s'est réjoui
voilà une hôtesse que son idée qui sont
reprises par le gouvernement il ya un
certain nombre de mesures dont on nous
dit qu'elles sont dans le texte et qui
satisfont
les élus de l'ump qui suivent ces
dossiers je m'en réjouis mais moi je
n'ai pas encore vu le texte je suis
député membre de la commission des lois
et par prudence peut-être aussi un peu
par vous allez dire conscience
professionnelle même si c'est pas
véritablement une profession je préfère
parler d'un texte quand je les lui
plutôt que d'en parler sans l'avoir lu
bon je ne sais pas encore ce qu'il ya
dans le détail dans ce texte j'attends
de le voir avec impatience parce que les
impératifs qui s'attache à la
préservation et au renforcement de notre
sécurité sont évidents nous vivons dans
un monde dangereux et nous savons qu'il
faut
être armé juridiquement et pas seulement
juridiquement face à ces menaces j'ai
toujours été pour ma part non pas
réticent mais mes
dubitatif sur l'intérêt qui s'attachait
à la création d'un instrument juridique
nouveau je ne dis pas que c'est inutile
et je ne dis pas qu'il ya peut-être très
bonnes choses dans ce texte je crois que
notre sujet tient plus à la question des
moyens matériels humains
budgétaire que à la question des
instruments juridiques dont nous aurions
besoin et je me méfie des réactions
c'est vrai à gauche comme à droite des
réactions qui disent la première chose à
faire face à des menaces c'est un
nouveau texte une nouvelle norme je
crois beaucoup plus au travail dans la
durée avec des moyens humains des moyens
financiers des moyens budgétaires
puisque des renforts ont été annoncés
aux graminées semaine il s'agit mais il
s'agirait de donner un cadre légal dit
on avec des garde-fous juridique à
l'action et bien des agents de
renseignement encore une fois je reste
mais alors est-ce que vous prétendre à
ce texte on s'est encore vu je me dis
juste votre méfiance je dis juste que
les sujets les plus sérieux me semble
être moins la question de
l'instrumentation juridique pour
permettre l'action des services que la
question des moyens dont disposent les
mêmes services pas simplement les
services de renseignement on voit bien
que dans le
dans le chaînon dans la chaîne des
éléments républicain en matière de
sécurité il y a des points faibles il y
en a un qui est très faible c'est la
prison parce que les moyens que le pays
attribuent au système carcéral depuis
des années ne sont pas véritablement
suffisant et donc la prison est souvent
un lieu de radicalisation de
débordements a lieu de préparation à des
suites qui sont dangereuses des mesures
ont été prises là on parle du
renseignement je disais il ya un je ne
sais pas si des mesures ont été prises
je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui nous avons
augmenté à ce point les moyens que nous
serions capables d'assurer l'isolément
complet des détenus dont nous
considérons qu'ils sont celles n'ayant
pas encore même à la maison et annoncé
attendre vos produits regroupés au lycée
mais alors là on parle d'une aisance et
mais cgfr bien consensus quand même là
qui s'est dégagée du mp on entend qu
réticences mais alors ce que vous être
un peu sur la même ligne que le front
national excusez moi de vous le dire qui
s'inquiète lui est ce qu'on va vers un
état big brother est ce que c'est aussi
un sujet d'inquiétude pour vous je pense
qu'encore une fois le savoureux que ce
soit le front national qui se posent en
défenseurs des libertés individuelles ou
des libertés publiques mon mais voilà
moi encore une fois mon sujet ce n'est
pas d'hier que ce qui a dans ce texte de
loi n'est pas satisfaisant je n'ai pas
vu je dis juste que si on veut être
efficace face aux menaces terroristes à
deux priorités il ya des priorités qui
sont plus délicates qui sont la question
des moyens dans le temps budgétaires
financiers humains si ce texte est
déposée le sera sur le bureau de
l'assemblée il sera j'imagine discuté en
commission des lois je le regarderai et
il est bien probable compte tenu de ce
que j'ai entendu de mes collègues qui
suivent ce dossier avec attention que je
participerai au vote et que je voterai
pour l'accord mets et encore une fois je
connais je connais trop les les les
grandes annonces et l'année c'est facile
de produire un texte c'est probablement
ce qui est plus simple dans un système
démocratique c'est produire un texte bon
faire les choses c'est plus compliqué
alors la question de la laïcité relancé
par la décision de votre collègue maire
ump de châlons sur saône de ne plus
proposer de menues de substitution quand
les cantines scolaires de sa ville
propose du port est ce que vous vous
pourriez prendre une telle mesure au
havre non non non moi ce que j'observe
c'est que je suis d'abord à titre
personnel extrêmement attachés au
principe de laïcité
extrêmement attachés à cette question
fait la laïcité qu'elle était jugée
soutenu d'ailleurs par nicolas sarkozy a
décidé de supprimer les menus de
succession lé maire de sa ville et il
fait bien comme il veut mais simplement
moi je me suis également au moins tout
autant attaché au principe de laïcité
pour moi le principe de laïcité c'est la
possibilité pour chacun de croire ou de
ne pas croire de pratiquer dignement sa
religion
sans imposer quoi que ce soit lié à la
religion aux autres et c'est la
nécessité pour la sphère publique d'être
dans une attitude de neutralité complète
vis-à-vis de la religion autant je suis
extrêmement ferme sur la participation
aux classes sur le respect des
programmes sur l'impossibilité qu'il y
aurait à modifier quelque chose établie
dans le cadre du cursus scolaire à
raison d'une religion autant je constate
primo que la cantine ça n'est pas du
temps scolaire ce n'est pas du temps
scolaire
deuxio que l'objectif des cantines c'est
quand même avant est avant tout de
permettre aux enfants de manger
équilibré dans de bonnes conditions il
ya 8000 demi pensionnaires au havre et
croyez moi pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux pas pour tous c'est souvent
le repas le plus équilibré de la journée
et troisièmement je ne vois pas en quoi
proposer quand il y à un menu à base de
porc un menu de substitution poser un
problème à la lester j'ajoute et
j'ajoute qui est évidemment aucune
prescription religieuse n'est appliquée
et ne doit être appliqué dans la
préparation des repas il ne s'agit pas
de cuisine et de la viande préparée de
telle ou telle façon pour répondre à un
impératif les soirs mais offrir le choix
et je vais vous dire en pratique faut
jamais avoir été dans une cantine pour
savoir pour en pratique qu'est ce qui se
passe dans toutes les cantines on
installe des selfs donc ça veut dire que
dans toutes les cantines de toute façon
on ne les appelle pas dans toutes les
cantines mais de plus en plus dans les
cantines on installe des selfs donc ça
veut dire que de toute façon les enfants
le choix donc je trouve qu'il ya là une
façon une femme soit d'abord des
problèmes qui tant d'autres choses dans
notre société non je sais par jean
cocteau questure elle je vous réponds je
sais pas je ne le souhaite pas mais je
vois de la possibilité de faire profiter
aux enfants des menus de substitution
l'immense majorité des communes
françaises aient jamais jamais on ne m'a
posé aucune question au havre est que
j'avais le sujet en question pourquoi
non mais pourquoi attendre à ce point le
débat est ce que j'ai et j'ai entendu
certains dire oui mais vous comprenez
s'ils ne veulent pas absolument manger
du porc ils n'ont qu'à aller dans des
écoles confessionnelles mais est ce
qu'on a envie de construire une société
dans lesquels en fonction de ses
appartenances religieuses on irait
systématiquement avec sa communauté
religieuse et moi c'est pas la
république dans laquelle j'ai envie de
vivre j'ai pas envie que les musulmans
soient dans des écoles musulmanes que
les catholiques soit dans des écoles
catholiques et que les autres ça n'a pas
de sens on essaie de créer une école
pour que les gens apprennent à vivre
ensemble et et autant on est inflexible
sur les programmes parce que là on a
du temps scolaire on est là aussi pour
respecter une certaine forme de liberté
de choix voilà bien et philippe c'est un
contre argument très nette aux propos de
nicolas sarkozy a écouté il est arrivé
lui justement il faut que les enfants
tout cas il dans les échos le président
il l'a dit le président de l'ump a
indiqué lors du dernier conseil national
qui aurait à l'ump une réflexion sur
toutes ces sujets il a eu raison de le
dire cette réflexion n'a pas encore eu
lieu
renchérit a fait des déclarations elle
son personnel il est parfaitement libre
d'y croire et de le dire mais il se
trouve que je suis aussi assez libre de
la gare et de dire éventuellement autre
chose parfois on est d'accord l'enfant
les mollahs grands désaccords également
par exemple sur l'interdiction des
élèves voilées dans les universités je
trouve la question difficile sauf
qu'elle est compliquée on a on a fait
une avancée importante
au début des années 2000 en 2004 avec la
loi interdisant le port du voile du
voile à l'école parce qu'elle doit
s'arrêter à l'université et quand on a
indiqué que nous ont placé les élèves
c'est à dire les usagers du service
public dans une obligation de neutralité
ce qui n'est pas la base de la loi de
1905 enfin quand on a dit ça
on l'a dit parce que dans l'école
régnier surtout chez des mineurs le
besoin de le besoin de respecter une
certaine forme de neutralité commune
chez des esprits qui n'était pas encore
formé reconnaissait avec moi quelle
université on est un peu dans un autre
système on est en face sur d'élèves
majeur à chaque fois des élèves qui
viennent de pays étrangers dm des
étudiants étrangers
on n'est pas exactement dans la même
situation je pense donc que la question
mérite à tout le moins un débat d'aquin
c'est très bien alors une question
encore d'actualité avec le député ump
patrick balkany qui a vu donc son
immunité parlementaire levée par ses
pairs il estime qu'on le jette au chien
est ce qu'il refuse de démissionner de
ses mandats et ce qu'il doit le faire
selon vous janot nom alors je d'abord
via pas démissionné de ses mandats parce
qu'il est mis en cause par la justice
patrick balkany il est comme tous les
français comme vous comme moi comme
n'importe quel français il a le droit la
présomption d'innocence tant qu'il n'est
pas reconnue coupable par un jury va par
là bas a jugé par une juridiction il n'a
aucune raison de démissionner de son
poste de député donc ce alors là de ce
point de vue là moi je suis très nettes
mais en revanche d'immunité je constate
que l'immunité parlementaire a été levée
à l'unanimité des membres du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale
qu'est ce que c'est l'immunité
parlementaire dans mon esprit c'est une
mesure qui protège le parlementaire
d'abus de l'exécutif ou du judiciaire
dans l'exercice de sa fonction parce
qu'on ne veut pas que l'exécutif ou
judiciaires entrave d'une certaine façon
et élections à nantes je crois que c'est
une protection qui reste pertinente mais
elle n'a pas pour objet et elle ne peut
pas avoir pour effet d'interdire à la
justice de poursuivre une procédure
conforme elle à la régulière conforme à
la loi vis-à-vis d'un parlementaire
j'observe si vous me permettez qu'un
certain nombre de parlementaires
lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à des
affaires de ce type demande de même la
levée de l'immunité parlementaire etc
évidemment le gros suit la banque a
d'ailleurs le même jour sénateur
centriste est vraiment et ça a été le
cas de philippe briand il ya quelques
semaines qui a demandé lui même la levée
de son immunité parlementaire il se
trouve que dans ce cas le bureau à
l'unanimité a demandé la levée de
liberté parce qu'il est parce qu il
avait accentué le fut rude pour être
toujours reste heureusement de capture
de l'ump monsieur balkany pour vous
cependant c'est une question qu'il faut
lui poser à lui qu'il faut bien se dire
ah non mais voilà bon mais très bien je
mangeais pas de jeu pas de souci avec
lui allez on va parler avec guillaume
daudin de la fp spécifiquement
maintenant de l'enjeu des
départementales dont le premier tour se
déroule dimanche qui de l'ump unis ou du
fn décrochera la pole position ce sera
le premier sujet le premier résultat
bien sûr observé dimanche soir pauline
dame
objectif premier pour la droite inverser
le rapport de forces sur 101
départements 60 sont aujourd'hui aux
mains de la gauche
selon les dernières projections 30 à 40
départements pourraient basculer en
faveur de la droite la reconquête du
terrain s'annonce bien
de quoi donner le sourire à jean pierre
raffarin le match qui s'annonce c'est un
match entre l'ump et le front national
et le parti socialiste s'est exclu
lui-même par ses échecs de ce débat
territoriales on connaît bien depuis le
calcul mitterrandienne l'intérêt qu'il
peut y avoir pour les socialistes de
faire monter le front national en
mettant au coeur du débat politique mais
au fond c'est l'arroseur arrosé une
victoire de la droite qui pourrait être
également renforcée par le nouveau mode
de scrutin redécoupage des cantons
relèvement du seuil des lecteurs pour se
maintenir au second tour ces nouvelles
règles pourrait coûter cher à la gauche
pourtant à l'origine de cette réforme le
relèvement du seuil de voix nécessaires
pour se qualifier pour le second tour va
diminuer le nombre de triangulaires que
des candidats devront obtenir un nombre
de voix égal à 12 5% des inscrits comme
on s'attend à une abstention très forte
c'est sans doute c'est très souvent plus
de 50% des voix qu'il faudra obtenir et
donc ça a pour conséquence que des
dizaines des centaines de candidats
socialistes ne pourront pas se qualifier
pour le second tour sans d'ironie du
sort
qui frappe la gauche
cette réforme électorale une fausse
bonne idée au sénat on ne s'alarme pas
pour autant c'était pas une bonne idée
c'était une obligation du conseil
constitutionnel donc il fallait la
parité et l'équité c'est ce qui a été
fait donc les modes de scrutin ça n'a
aucune mais aucune importance aucun
intérêt ce mode de scrutin pour la
première fois on va faire en sorte
qu'ils les 50 % de femmes eh bien rien
que pour cela je pense que ce mode de
scrutin il est bien un mode de scrutin
qui serait favorable à la droite mais
une victoire qui pourrait être assombrie
dimanche soir par le score du front
national voilà donc guillaume daudin
nous a rejoint avec déjà donc un
argument pour les socialistes des
mâchoires qui pourront se féliciter de
la victoire de la parité on a entendu on
sort de ce film pour ça donc le fn
pourrait emporter
1 deux peut-être trois départements en
tout cas pas plus l'ump va remporter de
ces projections peut-être 60 50 60 au
moins pourtant on a déjà l'impression
que c'est le fn qui est le grand
vainqueur de cette élection qu'est ce
que peut faire lui entre pour ça je suis
admiratif de votre capacité à faire
avant les résultats de l'élection
l'analyse de ce que les élections nous
montre moi je ne suis pas aussi
clairvoyant et je rentre pas dans le jeu
des des prévisions et des projections
parce que c'est pas du tout par rapport
aux vertus mais parce que il se trouve
que ça fait quand même quelques fois que
je me présente à des élections je suis
pas candidat cette fois ci mais que
j'envoie des élections ou que je me
présente et que je sais que c'est jamais
complètement joué avant donc elles
réservent toujours leur lot de surprises
et je ne me risque pas à aller à les
commenter avant qu'elle soit abordé
cette question d'une autre manière alors
dire que pendant toute la campagne le fn
et le ps et le gouvernement notamment
ont énormément parler de du front
national ça c'est vrai donc on peut se
dire que peut-être suite à suite à ça le
fn va être présenté comme le grand
vainqueur des élections quoi qu'il
arrive on est quasiment au terme de
cette campagne en tout cas de cette
campagne de premier tour et moi ce qui
me frappe
c'était au moins trois choses la
première c'est l'incroyable désintérêt
des électeurs pour l'élection qui vient
je le dis sans gaieté de coeur parce que
parce que je suis comme vous attaché à
la vie citoyenne à la vie publique et la
vie électorale et quand les électeurs
n'ont rien à faire de l'élection qui
vient ça ne me réjouit pas mais c'est un
fait les français ne s'intéressent pas
l'élection départementale qui vient
parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
véritablement ni le mode de scrutin ni
les cantons qui ont été redécoupée ni à
quoi sert le département il ya un an
leur a dit le département on va le
supprimer puis apprend leur dit non pas
le département certains départements car
on leur dit mais en fait on va surtout
s'occuper des régions var découper des
régions et on votera en 2000
franchement je ce que je constate au
havre c'est que ça ne suscite pas
l'intérêt on est quand même
difficilement capable d'expliquer
quelles sont les compétences du futur
département ou s'il va survivre au
prochain mandat donc un désintérêt 2 le
choix à mon avis critiquable du premier
ministre et d'une partie de la droite de
placer le front national au coeur de la
campagne sur le thème c'est vous qui le
faites monter non c'est vous non c'est
pas franchement c'est absurde c'est pas
le sujet d'une campagne électorale le
sujet d'une campagne électorale c'est à
quoi sert le département c'est comment à
financer les actions du département
c'est ya des sujets beaucoup entendu
l'ump là-dessus justement est-ce que
l'hymne national pour les développer
votre troisième - et peut-être passé
mais en tout cas moi je considère qu'il
ya eu une pauvreté du débat sur le fond
de l'avenir des départements ou de
l'avenir de tel ou tel département qui
était préoccupante ça c'est le deuxième
point le troisième point qui me frappe
en faisant campagne c'est c'est la
désaffection des français et y compris
des électeurs de la gauche pour le parti
socialiste
alors je ne sais pas quel score obtient
obtiendront les candidats du parti
socialiste mais ce que je constate c'est
que quand je me promène sur les marchés
au havre quand je vois une désaffection
est une déception et un
débit qui sont à mon sens manifeste et
qui pourront peut-être profiter à votre
formation peut-être peut-être on verra
on verra d'accord parce que le débit
n'est pas générale est ce qu'ils
n'expliquent pas quand même en partie la
poussée du front national de dettes
aussi intègre aussi peut-être à 6 jeux
lorsque il faut pas exclure que j'ai
toujours pensé que ça ne servait pas à
grand-chose de jeter l'anathème sur les
électeurs du front national sont des
citoyens français qui veulent qu'ils
font le choix de voter tel que leur
conscience ou leurs goûts leurs indics
et ça n'est pas critiquable je pense en
revanche que il est possible de
critiquer et de démonter le programme
les argumentations du front national
alors on peut le faire sujet par sujet
mais pour le faire de façon crédible il
faut être justement crédible et c'est
vrai que cette crédibilité ce travail
programmatique ce sérieux dans la
correspondance entre le discours et les
actes il fait défaut à la gauche et il a
souvent ou en tout cas parfois fait des
fois la droite il faut donc reconquérir
cette crédibilité pour pouvoir affronter
le front national n'ont pas sur le
terrain d'une posture morale mais sur le
terrain des idées des programmes et des
réalisations à vous souligner aussi les
manques de l'ump rue mans j'ai pas s'ils
soulignent le manque de liens brisés dis
ce que je pense quoi je veux dire voilà
je vais dans sa d'accord et justement
affrontement avec le fmi un certain
nombre de second tour de ces
départementale ça on en est déjà sûre où
il y aura des second tour fn ps comme ça
s'est produit dans la partielle du doubs
vous aviez l'ump avait avait exprimé une
position le ni ni vous aviez exprimé une
position un peu différente un appel à
faire barrage
au front national est ce que pour vous
asseoir à j'imagine la même position que
ces gars là les choses sont claires en
la matière le bureau politique de l'ump
a après en avoir délibéré a fait le
choix d'une ligne il consiste à dire
qu'il n'y avait pas de consigne de vote
et qu'on appelait ni à voter pour le
parti socialiste ni à voter pour le
front national c'est la ligne de l'ump
c'est là qu'on parlait pour cette
parcelle c'est la ligne de l'ump
généraux en matière électorale elle a
été définie clairement elle est le
résultat d'un vote et il n'y a aucune
raison de la contester dans dans la
légitimité dans laquelle elle est
exprimée en même temps nouveaux il se
trouve que avant qu'elle soit exprimé
j'ai indiqué moi petit personnel que ce
n'était pas la ligne qui me convenait
parce que moi à titre personnel je ne
mets pas le front national sur le même
plan que le parti socialiste je vous dis
pas que j'approuve le parti socialiste
mais je ne mets pas le front national
sur le même plan que le parti socialiste
je suis de ce point de vue minoritaire
dans ma famille politique mais c'était
finalement la position de nicolas
sarkozy sur la partielle du doubs aussi
je ne sais pas très bien mais en tout
cas ce que je sais c'est que ma position
personnelle et c'est là la position de
mon parti est très clair et je la
respecte et in fine et je me réjouis
d'être membre d'une famille politique où
il est aussi facile d'être dans la
minorité de pouvoir exprimer clairement
son point de vue en respectant le vôtre
celui de la majorité c'est bien naturel
c'est cette liberté politique cette
liberté intellectuelle qu'on a au sein
de l'ump
et bah je je m'en fous est ce que alain
juppé pourra l'a réaffirmé à beaucoup
tant de force qu'il va devoir être la
position qui est la même que la vôtre on
l'a compris en sourdine dans la
perspective de la primaire 2005 sûr je
suis chez moi je suis pas sûr que ils
aient envie de mettre quoi que ce soit
en sourdine dans la perspective de 2016
non donc quand il aura besoin de
s'exprimer quand il a envie de
s'exprimer le dr araxxe est nécessaire
il le fera comme il l'a fait depuis les
six derniers mois censure occuper le
terrain sans
mais en disant clairement ce qui marque
cette liberté de parole vous félicite et
on la doit peut-être à la nouvelle
présidence de nicolas sarkozy justement
il ne l'a pas remis en cause elle
existait auparavant
c'est vous savez c'est une valeur
fondatrice est une valeur fondamentale
de la droite et de la droite et du
centre la liberté la liberté
intellectuelle la liberté d'expression
et jamais il m'est arrivé d'être dans le
bloc majoritaire à l'ump il m'arrive
parfois d'être dans le bloc minoritaire
de jamais personne ne m'a fait grief ou
ne m'a critiqué parce que je formuler
une opinion politique argumentez et je
trouve que c'est assez louable donc je
vois je vois parfois et pardon je lis je
vois parfois chez mes collègues à
l'assemblée nationale au sein du parti
socialiste des pressions très fortes qui
s'exerce sur les votes je n'ai jamais à
l'ump subit de telles pressions c'est
vous parliez d'une position minoritaire
donc c'est une position qui était
minoritaire en bureau politique au sein
des instances de l'ump c'est aussi une
position qui est largement minoritaire
au sein de la base de l'ump peut-être
qui a eu des sondages un sympathisant
ump sur deux favorables à des alliances
locales avec le fn au final est ce
qu'avec alain juppé vous n'avez pas le
sentiment d'être voilà d'être un peu
déconnecté d'une base ump qui se
radicalise ray vers le fn déconnecter en
aucune façon peut-être pas toujours sur
la même ligne encore une fois je trouve
ça très simple vous savez quand quand
vous avez fait le choix de vous engager
dans la vie politique vous ne faites pas
systématiquement en pensant que vous
allez sur tous les sujets tout le temps
être d'accord avec l'immense majorité il
ya des sujets sur lesquels vous savez
que vous avez encore un travail de
conviction de persuasion ben voilà c'est
ça fait partie du ca fait un moyen du
boulot bien sûr et ça pourrait être un
boulot assez conséquent pour gagner la
primaire de 2016 et aboulaye on verra on
verra moi je crois pas je crois que la
primaire de 2016 elle sera très
largement ouvertes tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs
républicaines de la droite et du centre
et je constate qu'à chaque fois que
alain juppé à formuler la position qui
était la sienne ou à chaque fois que je
le fais moi il y a eu je constate qu'il
ya des gens qui ne sont pas contents
mais julia parfum dans les derniers
peut-être régions l'ump mais je vois
aussi beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'électeurs de la droite et du
centre qui ne sont pas forcément de
l'ump qui nous disent vous avez raison
c'est le bon sens et puis je vais
terminer par un sujet qui est quand même
assez savoureuse alain juppé s'est fait
siffler dans des réunions ump au moment
où il indiquait que pour gagner les
élections il fallait les préparer en
travaillant à des alliances entre la
droite et les centres et là un certain
nombre de membres de l'ump le cif parce
qu'ils considèrent que c'est une erreur
d'analysé qui ne veulent pas de bayrou
ils ont parfaitement le droit de le
penser mais qu'est ce que j'observe dans
l'ensemble des départements français y
compris dans les départements où sont
élus les plus durs sur cette position
les plus opposées à cette position chez
qui l alliance avec lui des mercenaires
c'est mon cas des alliances avec le
modem donc il faut il faut aussi savoir
ce qu'on veut il faut aussi parler en
conséquence ce qu'elle formule alain
juppé pour gagner en 2017 il faudra
travailler à une alliance qui n'est pas
une soumission qui n'est pas une mais à
une alliance politique pour prévoir un
gouvernement pour savoir avec qui on
gouverne avec les centres c'est à mon
avis l'expression du bon sens
et il ya beaucoup de français qui se
reconnaissent le dos alors en tant qu en
tant qu ancien élève de sciences po j'ai
noté que vos amis et les démonstrations
en trois points avait obéi tout à
l'heure notamment un troisième point
vous avez constaté sur le terrain que
les électeurs de gauche abandonnait le
parti socialiste est ce que vous espérez
qu'ils pourraient venir sur alain juppé
par exemple en 2017 présenté parfois
comme aussi un candidat préféré de la
gauche
je suppose us est le candidat préféré de
la gauche d'abord je voudrais tordre le
cou à une
à une idée que je crois fausse je ne
pense pas que les électeurs socialistes
et que la gauche en général viendra
participer à la primaire ouverte je n'y
crois pas je pense que il y aura six
vous organisons bien les choses un peu
plus de 3 millions de français qui
viendront il faudra qu'ils les
approuvent localement dans leurs bureaux
de vote dans leurs villes dans leurs
villages le fait qu'ils partagent les
valeurs de la droite et du centre et de
la même façon que la droite ne s'est pas
déplacé pour aller voter pour manuel
valls qui était le chouchou de la droite
à la primaire socialiste je vous fiche
mon billet si vous me passez
l'expression la gauche ne viendra pas
voter pour alain juppé au moment des
primaires
après les primaires alors si si après
les primaires si vous parlez d'après les
primaires si vous parlez du premier tour
d'élection présidentielle ou même du
deuxième moi je crois que là la question
est posée on sait on s'agite tous le
monde médiatique le monde politique sur
qui est en mesure de gagner les
primaires et sur qui est en mesure de
gagner l'élection présidentielle c'est
très intéressant surtout pour les
principaux concernés mais ce n'est pas
l'essentiel l'essentiel il faut de
guerre c'est ce qu'on fait après c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait et avec qui on
gouverne et pour l'instant je ne vois
pas cette question posée et je trouve
que la capacité qu'a alain juppé a parlé
très au delà de sa famille politique
avec les centres à engager parfois des
discussions
qui pointe les désaccords mais qui ne me
connaissent pas non plus les possible
convergence
et bah je pense que c'est intéressant
pour le pays voilà et donc et j'ai
l'impression là aussi qu'un grand nombre
de français sont sensibles c'est à dire
un appel aux électeurs de gauche alors
de nom il y aura un premier tour
d'élection présidentielle un deuxième
temps d'action présidentielle et les
français feront ce qu'ils veulent
j'avais soyez soyez certains ils font
vraiment ce qu'il veut ben justement
alain juppé candidat de l'ump
imaginons en 2017 à la présidentielle
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un immense espace
qui est ouvert entre l'ump et le front
national pour marine le pen est ce que
vous pensez pas écoutés au
écoutez on verra moi je crois pas je
crois pas et ce qui sera pas amené à un
moment justement à j'ai vu en 2012 une
campagne présidentielle où les choix qui
avait été fait et et les choix d'une
grande agressivité d'une grappe à une
très droitière entre guillemets sous
influence de l'éminence dont doit
rallier tout à l'heure
ça montrait que ça marchait pas ça a
montré qu'au deuxième tour on n'avait
pas beaucoup mangé à l'extrême droite
mais qu'on avait perdu les voix du
centre et que donc on a perdu l'élection
présidentielle je trouve que ça devrait
faire réfléchir dans le figaro de ce
mercredi auprès de ce mot à nicolas
sarkozy juppé c'est rocard contre
mitterrand c'est balladur contre chirac
c'est pas très prometteurs comme
comparaison basse était normal que
nicolas sarkozy
ne se place pas dans la peau du perdant
voilà voilà très bien merci guillaume va
aller on va partir pour le havre
maintenant à votre ville le port et le
championnat national mais on le sait sur
ce terrain là la france a régressé ces
dernières années alors où en sommes-nous
après les projets ambitieux qui avait
été évoquée est liée au grand paris
c'est ce qu'a voulu savoir audrey états
le projet était ambitieux pharaonique
avec le grand paris nicolas sarkozy
voulait ttendre la capitale jusqu'au
havre en suivant la vallée de la seine
pour cela il avait vu les choses en
grand une ligne tgv paris normandie le
développement des réseaux routiers et
l'extension du port du havre pour qu'il
redevienne leader en europe c'était en
2009 problème si les ambitions étaient
là les financements eux ne l'était pas
on avait ces discours qui relève
finalement de la caricature
malheureusement il y en a eu beaucoup et
on est passé aujourd'hui un projet qui
est financé
et qui est raisonnable en terme de
calendrier ce projet plus réaliste a été
acté le 13 février 2015 à l'occasion
d'un contrat de plan état région pour la
vallée de la seine au final ce contrat
de plan c'est un milliard d'euros donc
on est passé des paroles aux actes ce
financement devrait permettre de
développer notamment le transport des
marchandises par le fret c'est un sujet
majeur parce qu'on veut plus de
marchandises passent par le train parce
qu'il ya ça fait moins de camions sur la
route c'est moins dangereux et fait
moins polluants l'enjeu est aussi
économique car le port du havre continue
sa mutation son nouveau fleuron port
2000 lui permet de recevoir les plus
gros porte conteneurs du monde je dirais
c'est
l'investissement qui permet au port du
havre aujourd'hui de rester dans la cour
des grands en matière de port à
conteneurs les conteneurs étant notre
notre activité principale aujourd'hui
est celle qui présente les perspectives
de développement les plus importantes à
l'avenir mais ces conteneurs il faut les
évacuer c'est la raison pour laquelle il
est primordial de développer le fret qui
ne représente pour l'instant que 5 % du
transport des marchandises au havre des
ambitions de développement que les
havrais observe de loin pour ceux qui ne
travaillent pas le port c'est un peu un
concept flou rapport ça évolue le port
cet au fil des années éloigné de la
ville pour y remédier la municipalité et
le port travaillent ensemble au
réaménagement du quai southampton
le projet devrait voir le jour en 2017
pour les 500 ans de la ville ce nouvel
espace propice à la promenade devrait
permettre une meilleure cohabitation
entre les activités urbaines et celle du
cinquième port d'europe voilà
vos questions et donc député maire du
havre
et pas seulement le livre que je vois
sur votre bureau on en parlait dans un
instant des paroles aux actes avis le
président du conseil régional de
normandie est-ce que l'actuel
gouvernement a su concrétiser finalement
cet axe paris le havre cet axe hossein
que nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas su mener
à terme bon je voudrais essayer de pas
être aussi caricaturale que ce qui l'a
été dans son petit sujet c'est vrai que
on peut dire que avant la gauche il ne
se passait rien et que depuis que la
gauche a été élu il se passerait tout en
vérité ce n'est pas exactement comme ça
que ça fonctionne il faut d'abord
reconnaître à nicolas sarkozy président
de la république
une intuition est tout à fait
remarquable et l' envie de ne pas
marquer son passage aux affaires
simplement par la construction à paris
d'un grand objet architectural mais bien
par l'idée d'envisager le développement
de paris de l'île de france autour de
l'axé seine avec une logique simple
capter les flux qu'elle ça veut dire
capter les flux faut bien le comprendre
parce que les gens ne sont pas très
coutumier avec la nature de ce qu'est
l'activité portuaire 80 81 85 % du
commerce physique de marchandises sur la
planète et portuaire et maritime et
portuaire c'est incroyable ce chiffre ça
veut dire que quand on capte les flux
quand on arrive à part des ports
efficace capter les flux on a toutes les
chances de relocaliser la production
industrielle et de créer des emplois et
le projet de grand paris c'est ça c'est
d'adosser paris et son développement à
un grand port qui lui permet d'être dans
la course à la mondialisation c'est ça
son idée ça c'est ce que le gouvernement
actuel a concrétisé à la suivre ce que
disait donc le gouvernement actuel est
ce que dans les majeures de la région
sous la précédente majorité on a vendu
cette idée on a essayé de diffuser cette
idée de convaincre l'ensemble des
acteurs on a lancé des débats publics et
on a pris la décision de christ de
construire une ligne nouvelle entre le
havre et paris pour désengorger la ligne
de fret et pour pouvoir donc muscler
l'activité le portuaire aujourd'hui on
est en 2015 pendant un an le
gouvernement a laissé sans responsable
ce projet ils ont démis antoine
ruffenach qui était au commissaire au
développement de la vallée de la seine
et puis ils n'ont rien fait et un
horizon nommer un préfet
il n'est pas abandonné quels sont les
actes qui ont été pris récemment la
décision de financer des études c'est
bien donc là jusqu'à 2020 on fait des
études c'est formidable aux finances des
études la question n'est pas tellement
le financement des études la question
c'est vous le comprenez bien le
financement des travaux or qu'est-ce qui
devait financer les travaux le produit
de l'écotaxe à travers la fit qu'aux
taxes y en a plus d'accord donc les
questionnements et les interrogations
sur le financement ultérieur des travaux
sont réels c'est la première chose mais
peut-être plus grave encore quelles sont
les décisions prises par ce gouvernement
la décision prise par ce gouvernement
c'est de privilégier le canal seine nord
donc d'aller vers les grands ports du
nord de la don peut présenter à l'union
européenne un projet pour obtenir les
financements de l'union européenne qui a
une logique qui est quasiment pas
contradictoire on va dire pas
contradictoire mais assez peu
complémentaire avec la logique de l'axé
seine parce que si vous favorisez les
ports d'anvers et les ports de rotterdam
qui sont les plus performants
aujourd'hui eh bien vous vous financez
avec des investissements français la
compétitivité d'un verre et rotterdam
vous préférez vrai que la france a envie
légier le port du harnais et le port de
rouen et permettre dans l'axé seine et
autour de l'axé seine la création de
valeur ajoutée la relocalisation du
havre va mourir à petit feu non il va
pas mourir à petit feu parce que c'est
un port qui se bat parce que il ya des
professionnels parfaitement compétent
parce qu'il ya une envie de reprendre
des parts de marché je me permets de
vous faire observer que le port du havre
reprend année après année des parts de
marché à anvers et rotterdam il est
beaucoup plus de tic anvers et rotterdam
mais il reprend année après année des
parts de marché en vous faites alors
parce que la france est sur le déclin
parce qu'il ya eu assez vite et
portuaires
vous détrompez vous détrompez vous le
gouvernement précédent je suis désolé de
devoir le citer mais le gouvernement
précédent avait pris la décision de
rapprocher le port du havre le port de
rouen le port de paris de créer un
système portuaire ça s'appelle arpin qui
a une politique commerciale unifiée qui
a une politique d'aménagement unifiée et
qui permet à ces trois permis de
regagner des parts de marché notamment
de regagner des parts de marché donc ne
ne pensons pas qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir
pour tuer en france ça n'est pas vrai il
ya des installations exceptionnelles il
ya des compétences exceptionnelles les
compétiteurs sont très bons anvers et
rotterdam et hambourg ils sont très bons
mais c'est pas parce qu'ils sont très
bons quand on est plus bête que on peut
continuer à faire valoir des arguments
nautique géographique et humain que cet
accord alors quelques mots sur vous
peut-être edouard philippe parce que
peut-être que tous les spectateurs et
téléspectateurs pardon ne vous
connaissent pas bien j'ai vu que vous
avez été encarté pendant deux ans en pf
oui j'étais j'étais étudiant à l'époque
parce que c'est vraiment socialiste non
mais c'est je dors je n'en ai aucune
espèce de deux ans était étudiant je
venais d'un milieu mes parents étaient
professeurs professeur de français
j'ai grandi dans un monde qui était
plutôt un monde acquis à la gauche et
par mes lectures par mes contacts j'ai
été assez sensible au discours de michel
réduction c'est bien sûr bien sûr les
machines
remonter c'est c'était mes convictions
le michel rocard parce que il proposait
de régler la question des eaux
calédoniennes avec une méthode nouvelle
aujourd'hui de cette conviction
d'étudiants et bell ont évolué elles ont
évolué parce que ben parce que parce que
tout le monde évolue entre le moment où
on a vingt ans et où on vit et d'un
délivré dans des études équipements
françois mais je je je continue à voir
une estime aurel pour michel rocard je
continue à voir des amis que l'injure
est aussi ça tombe bien et sort des
biens connaît bien sûr mais ce n'est pas
et ça n'est pas grave et ce n'est pas
scandaleux non mais ce serait même l'un
vers ce qui serait qui s'aggrave donc
donc voila mais ensuite progressivement
par mes responsabilités professionnelles
par robert encontre par mes lectures par
mon évolution personnelle j'ai plutôt
privilégier le libéralisme sur la social
démocratie voilà
annoncé un
déclic se fait pas non mais voilà une
évolution alors je me suis je me suis
converti
à la fois un gaullisme en matière de
deux
postures internationales
un libéralisme modéré enfin réels en
matière à la fois de moeurs et
d'économie il fera de questions sociales
très à droite est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être une espèce en voie
de disparition
l'egypte a le sentiment qu être un
libéral modéré ça vous place dans la à
partie en voie de disparition non non
pas du tout pas du tout si vous deviez
choisir entre laurent wauquiez manuel
valls tech et vous vous sentez le plus
proche
je vous dirais bien que ça dépend des
sujets
laurent wauquiez il est membre il est
membre de la même famille politique que
moi mais j'ai des désaccords ont connu
j'allais dire documenté avec lui même si
je le connais bien et même si on a des
relations tout à fait
conviviale manuel valls se critiquent sa
politique je ne la partage pas je ne
partage pas les fonds dans les
fondements de s'en aller je critique les
mesures qu'il prend je le trouve à bien
des égards très léger sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais j'estime le
bonhomme j'estime le bonhomme pardon
c'est un peu triviale par un prémice
mais j'estime l'homme à chaque fois que
je le rencontre nous avons des relations
qui sont très conviviale très
républicaine et je vais pas non plus me
cacher vous écrivez aussi des polars on
en parlait tout à l'heure alors si j'ai
apporté celui ci qui s'appelle dents
longues qui a été publiée en 2011 parce
qu'il raconte l'histoire d'un conseiller
de l'ombre engagés derrière son patron
qui est un homme politique candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et tout ça sur
fond de primaires truqués c'est donc
depuis 2011 devenir un peu à livre
d'anticipation politique avec la sphère
copé fillon non oui ça c'est vrai que
oui on a eu on a eu du nez on a eu du
pif on a écrit ce livre sans imaginer
qu'un jour il avec gilles boyer mon ami
est un autre conseiller d'essayer
d'alain juppé on a écrit ce livre pour
essayer de décrire de l'intérieur ce qui
était un entourage politique est ce que
pouvait être un entourage quand les
conditions de température et de pression
venait à changer et à devenir plus
compliqué et voilà alors le pitch c'est
ça c'est qu'est ce qui se passe quand on
apprend que la primaire qui a permis de
désigner le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle aurait peut-être été
truqué bon
en tout cas ça nous a imposé à réfléchir
à comment est-ce qu'on organisait une
primaire et cette réflexion n'est sans
doute pas inutile en ce moment
etc etc ceci dit c'est
dans les écoles de journalisme
mais c'est un manuel étudiants sont les
relations avec les médias si c'est un
manuel de survie pour un homme politique
quand j'entendais dans le processus des
premières vous avez certainement déjà dû
lui servir alain juppé à boyle à lui il
a même lu les épreuves avant qu'ils
soient publiés à très bien je peux
apporter des corrections qui a conseillé
à sacrifier presque tel presque toute sa
vie pour une campagne pour un homme
politique vous n'avez pas été chercher
très loin vos modèles d'inspiration à
bassoues pas de mode dont il s'agit je
peux vous dire mais parce que je ne me
prends pas la tête
vous essayez d'être remercié j'essaye
j'ai pas la prétention d'être romancier
mais quand vous essayez d'être un
romancier vous mettez une part de vous
même dans les personnages que vous crème
et vous mettez pas que vous même dans
les personnages que l'on crée non j'ai
un peu de distance avec tout ça comme
vous continuez à écrire et c'était un
autre livre en préparation j'avais que
c'est notre deuxième celui là dans
l'ombre avec gilles boyer on en avait
publié en 2007 qui s'appelait l'heure de
vérité on était parti pour en écrire un
troisième et c'est vrai que depuis
qu'alain juppé annoncé que il était
quand il était candidat ça nous pousse à
nous à ça nous a pris un petit peu de
temps donc le troisième on va attendre
un peu est ce que vous vous avez le
temps de lire parce qu'on a pu voir
parce que par exemple les agriculteurs
n'avaient pas tout le temps le temps de
lire oui moi je l'y ai pas joli joli
beaucoup moins que ce que j'aimerais et
puis je n'ai pas la prétention de tout
lire mais j'essaie de lire j'ai quelques
jets oui j'essaie de lire mais je lis en
ce moment beaucoup de livres sur
l'histoire de l'antiquité romaine sur la
fin de la république et sur le début de
l' empire sur les guerres puniques sur
voilà j'aime bien l'histoire en des
choses sur la politique actuelle
peut-être peut-être non j'aime j'aime
bien lire j'ai vu que nathalie kosciusko
morizet avait démissionné la haute
fonction publique michel a rappelé tout
à l'heure vous avez fait notamment l'ena
bon de le maire a également démissionné
est-ce que vous c'est quelque chose que
vous envisagez
écoute et vous ça vous semble utile
cette démarche un peu de transparence
vis-à-vis de ses électeurs non sans
émotion salle c'est pas une démarche de
transparence
par an je moi je me consacre à mes
mandats uniquement j'ai une vie
professionnelle où j'ai commencé ma vie
professionnelle comme fonctionnaire
pendant cinq ans au conseil d'état après
je suis parti travaille avec alain juppé
à l'ump donc en disponibilité dans le
privé enfin je suis parti dans un
cabinet d'avocats américain quand j'ai
été travaillé chez areva dans une
entreprise publique française
non mais non mais simple entre quoi je
vous dire je ne suis pas
particulièrement fier de mon cv mais moi
j'ai la caractéristique à 44 ans d'avoir
travaillé dans une boîte américaine dans
une boîte industrielle française dans la
fonction publique je pense que d'une
certaine façon ça m'aide en tout cas ça
me constitue et que dans mon analyse des
problèmes économiques ça m'aide un peu
donc je le regrette pas 7,7 ce parcours
professionnel je ne m'en offusque pas au
contraire je l'assumé et je pense qu'il
est un plus dans ma vie politique
aujourd'hui je me consacre qu'à mes
mandats le mandat de député le mandat de
maire du havre peut-être qu'un jour
j'arrêterai la vie politique c'est même
probable je retournerai peut-être
peut-être dans la fonction publique on
arrive peut-être dans le privé parce que
comme j'ai fait les deux et plutôt un
peu plus de priver de fonction publique
je sais pas démago ils ont parfaitement
le droit de prendre cette décision et de
l'annoncé et si un jour ils veulent
interdire à quiconque le droit d'asile
de front à une loi et puis voilà mais
pour l'instant je je je respecte assez
scrupuleusement la loi combien de fois
par jour ou par semaine vous parler
alain juppé on se voit non non non non
alain juppé il n'a pas besoin c'est
proche d'être pendu au téléphone et
comprend les choses assez rapidement et
on avisera
on se voit le mercredi matin tous les
mercredis matin et on s'appelle en tant
que de besoin
vous appellera peut-être après cette
émission merci à voir finir super et une
transformation a très vite merci
que